يبحث مجلس المحافظين التابع للوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه مناقشه مشروع قرار
اوروبي امريكي جديد ضد ايران بسبب مواقعها
النوويه السريه مصادر دبلوماسيه اد- اكدت
للعربيه ان مشروع القرار الغربي حول ايران
يحظى باجماع كبير وسيتم تبنيه باغلبيه
كبيره اشارت مصادر الدبلوماسيه للعربيه
الى ان لهجه البيان اقصى من القرار السابق
في يونيو ويحمل تلميحا الى امكانيه حاله
ملف ايران الى مجلس الامن في حال
استمرارها بعدم التعاون كان مدير الوكاله
رفاييل جراسيا قد قال امس انه لا يجوز لا
يبقى التحقيق في اثار يورانيوم سريه
مفتوحه للابد من دون الحصول على جواب في
ما حضر سفيره الاتحاد الاوروبي حضر ايران
من ان عدم تعاونها السريع مع الوكاله
سيؤدي الى تصعيد اكبر وان الدول الغربيه
تناقش خطواتها المقبله في حال لم تبدي
ايران تعاونا سريعا قال لا دبلوماسيه
اوروبيه للعربيه ان لدى الدول الغربيه
خيارات كثيره يمكنها اللجوء اليها في حال
لم تتعاون ايران بشكل سريع
الاتحاد الاوروبي من جانبه اتهم ايران
بانها لم تتخذ بعد الاجراءات اللازمه في
ما يتعلق بالقضايا العالقه في ملف
الضمانات النوويه قالت بعثه الاتحاد
الاوروبي امام مجلس المحافظي الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه في فيينا ان طهران
لم تقدم تفسيرات ذات مصداقيه فنيه بشان
الضمانات واشارت الى المخاوف الجده بشان
وجود مواد نوويه في مواقع غير معلنه في
ايران البعثه الاوروبيه اعربت عن القلق
البالغ من ان الموقع الحالي لهذه المواد
النوويه غير معروف للوكلات الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه
المزيد معنا من فينا مفردات العربيه الى
هناك راغده بهنام اهلا بك ماذا لدينا من
معلومات حول مشروع القرار هذا اين وصلنا
راغده
مرحبا ميسون يعني كان هناك استراحه ظهرا
يعني مجلس المحافظين ومن المفترضين مقابل
دقائق من الان عاده المجتمعون الى داخل
القاعه وكما فهمت سيطرح مشروع القرار يعني
فورا اعادت عوده انعقاد هذا المجلس يعني
في اي لحظه يمكن ان يتم التصويت على هذا
القرار ايضا كما فهمت من اكثر
دبلوماسيه تحدثت اليه بانه همم هناك عدد
كبير من الدول داخل مجلس المحافظين ستصوت
لصالح المشروع او بانه الدول الغربيه
مرتاحه لان هذا المشروع سيتم تمريره همم
بسهوله باغلبيه كبيره ليست هناك مخاوف
يعني من عرقلته همم السؤال اهم ما هو
سيكون رد فعل ايران هناك ترقق كبير ليرتفع
لايران همم دبلوماسي اوروبي ايضا كنت
اتحدث معه وسالته ما اذا كان هناك مخاوف
من ان تعقد يعني يعقد هذا القرار الجديد
المرتقب العلاقه اكثر مع ايران قال بانه
الوضع الان سيء جدا بمعنى الى اي مدى يمكن
ان اكثر ااا يعني يبدو بانه ليست هناك
مخاوف لدى هذه الدول الغربيه التي طرحت
المشروع من ان يؤدي هذا القرار يعني عندما
يتم تبنيه الى يعني تعقيد لوضع اكثر لانه
هي هي تعتقد ان الوضع سيء جدا ويعني هكذا
قرار لا يمكن ان يعقد الوضع اكثر مما هو
معقد اصلا
ليس هناك من ردود فعل او تصريحات همم
ايرانيه في هذا الاطار وبالمقابل ان لم
يكن هناك من خوف من خلال اتخاذ هذا القرار
من قبل هذه الدول ماذا عن ايران لماذا
ستتخوف لانه بحسب ما افهم اذا ما حول الى
مجلس الامن فهناك روسيا والصين لدعممها
يعني الان ما زال ربما الحديث يعني مبكر
قليلا للحديث عن حاله اللي مجلس الامن
لانه سيكون هناك اشهر بضعه اشهر ثلاثه
اربعه ربما سته اشهر امام ايران يعني ربما
قبل ان يتم حالتها او تبحث هذه الدول
جنسيا باحالتها الى مجلس الامن لان هناك
تلويح في هذا القرار كما فهمت في هذا
المشروع بي انه هذه امكانيه ولكن ليس هناك
قرار متحده بتوقيع هذا بتوقيت هذا الامر
حالات المجلس الامن بالفعل يمكن ان يصطدم
بعرقله روسيا ولكن يمكن ايضا ان يعود اذا
ما تم دمجه مع مساله اتفاق النووي يمكن ان
يعود ان يعيد همم بنقطه سنابك يمكن ان
يعيد على العقوبات فورا على ايران او يمكن
ان يعني يحصل البحث ان ذلك في مجلس الامن
ويخرج من سلطه الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه هنا همم هي تعتبر خطوه تصاعديه حتى
ولو اصطدميه يعني لا حقا بعرقها روسيه
هناك ولكن تعتبر تصعيد بانه هذا الملف
عادي الى مجلس الامن الاولى منذ ان عادت
ايران التعاون يعني وبدات المفاوضات التي
ادت لاتفاق العام 2015 الرد الفعل
الايراني سنسمعه من دون شك بعد ان يستر
هذا يعني التصويت والقرار ولكن يوم امس او
قبل او اول امس كان هناك كلام لمحمد
اسلامي رئيس الوكاله الذريه الايرانيه
قالوا انه يعني اشعاري لانه الاتفاق مع
الوكاله قبل اسبوع على ان تكون هناك زياره
ليكاله لطهران للبحث هذه المساله تحديدا
لبحث مساله همم اثار اليوراني والتي عثر
عليها في اماكن سريه قد لا تحصل همم لذلك
ننتظر وتنتظر الوكاله ايضا كما قال جروسي
امس ما اذا كانت ايران سترغي هذه الزياره
امام انها ستعود وتلتزم بها
يعني تعتبرها الوكاله مقبوله
العربيه الى هناك شكرا جزيلا لك